to a large degree to the people up in
the balcony because I've been a bench
scientist for a long time I thought it
might be fun to tell the majors in these
notebooks with you and show you the
various things that have happened in so
the pictures that I want to show you
but what I did find was a problem that
the insulin and when I tried to study it
by filter paper electrophoresis up there
which was one of the methods available
at that time
just unrolled like a carpet it didn't
migrate properly at all and I was
probably disappointed but then I heard
of Saturday again
notice I heard of some work going on in
the Hospital for Sick Children where
they were using another method they were
using starch grains as a supporting
medium instead of filter paper and they
made rather like a salmon pie the moist
starch grains and they allowed the
protein to migrate through this starch
around these starch grains and then cut
it up into about 40 slices and did a
protein determination on every slice in
order to get one electrophoresis rung
rather laborious I didn't even have a
dishwasher I couldn't afford to do 40
slices of the analysis to get one
electrophoresis run but I remembered
helping my mother to do the laundry when
I was a child and that when she starts
my father's collars that if it was let
sit around it turned into a jelly and I
thought well maybe then I couldn't
instead of using starch grains I can
cook the starch or make a gel and then
all I need to do is stain it instead of
doing all this business and that would
save a lot of trouble so I tried it
Saturday afternoon
Oh since we're on the topic of Saturday
I should say that on Saturday you can do
or what I call Saturday morning
experiments which means that you don't
have to weigh anything and it doesn't
have to be rational you can do anything
you like on Saturday so so this was it
Ania and I tried this and you can see
they're about it and I made the remark
but the result is very promising because
there's my insulin migrating now has a
little band instead of as a as an
unrolled carpet but there was something
else about this which was actually very
accidental I had nothing to do with it
being important and that was that in
order to make this gel I had to use a
very high concentration of the starch it
would not gel until it was a high
concentration so quite accidentally I'd
invented a molecular sieve
electrophoresis which turned out to be
quite powerful and you've often used it
in your poly acrylamide gel so that was
a complete accident but I I did then for
interest to try looking at the blood
proteins and I found that I get
excellent separation and many more
proteins I could see then people had at
that point thought were present in blood
so I stopped working on insulin and
began to work on blood proteins and I
was about ready to publishing and these
are two patents from my friend I had to
get blood from somebody
one was George Connell and the other was
Gordon Dixon and I'll refer to them
again later they both very distinguished
individuals he became president of the
University of Toronto at a later stage
in life but anyway that I was about
ready to publish this and and but then
one day one day I ran a sample from a
woman and it was quite different look at
this most odd many extra components all
of these extra bands I thought I found a
new way of telling men from wearing